one of the things about cancer the the
the one way to to think about cancer is
to ask the question why is there ever
anything but cancer in other words
individual cells like amibas are
extremely competent on their own they
handle single cell level goals quite
well why do they ever get together to
form something like a kidney or a liver
because when you have when when there's
a cancer what you're seeing is a
defection from that process you're
seeing cells that normally should be
working on making a nice organ in or
upkeeping a nice organ in an adult
instead of that they go off and they
basically revert to a single cell kind
of existence if you enjoyed that clip
then the full podcast is out right now
you can click around here enjoy
subscribe to theories of everything to
get notified of upcoming podcasts as
there are new fulllength podcasts every
week on the topics of mathematics
physics Consciousness Free Will and AI